welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
sitting here with my two
distinguished guests wonderful wonderful
gentlemen
joey salads the salad man camera do i
look at
that that one's your camera yeah
the saladino man himself thanks for
coming i appreciate you coming here
because obviously
you know it's kind of a lion's den for
pranksters oh yeah yeah i mean
but we're we're cool yeah no we're cool
i love your videos on me thank you and
and then with us as well is my boy good
old friend of the show
sean stinks great guy hey everybody out
there watching
one of my old old friends he used to i'm
for you guys who've been with us a long
time sean used to be in all of our
videos back in israel
oh yeah they're all private now aren't
they not all of them some of them are
classics like the kissing pranks when
you choked me out
when you weren't dragged i was thinking
about that on the way over that's a
great one and like the will i am the
pulse
i mean some real classics sean is over
on twitch currently
sean stinks give him a watch it's great
stuff
yeah you know it's a modest little
stream just hang out chat game it
[ __ ] yeah so interesting and
oh god am i not here sure
yeah i'm sorry dude somehow sometimes i
man spread
ela out of and completely out of
existence yeah
um we're here with the honestly the
ela kleiner it's the ela cliner
and we got a camera today we got a
camera on ela before you were
manspreaded out of the whole show
now we have a camera we got a mic you're
here welcome ela
thank you kind of like your first time
in the show kind of because before you
remember camera
yeah so joey tell me how are you dude
i'm
great i'm how are you i'm very good cool
like i was saying it's really nice so
joey's
you're i think the only prankster that i
can like have a conversation with like
we talk
on twitter dms and like we've always
been in touch i'll send you videos
you're like this is crazy please please
but i love that about you because on one
hand
it's respectable and it's lovable
because you don't take yourself
seriously you know that you're
a kind of a meme do you see yourself as
a meme um i'm less of a meme now than i
was
probably a year ago how do you feel
about that do you want to be more of a
man
in some ways i do in some ways i don't
break that down uh
that the memeage of last year was pretty
pretty hardcore me image you got the the
piss
yeah the boob you kind of hit them on
all cylinders knocked it out the park
this year i mean have i done anything
this year that
could meme me i don't know you had some
really nice um well you did that you had
the pokemon
adopt abduction i think that was you've
been hot yeah
was that last year you've been hot on
the abduction stuff though were you
abducted
is it like what's your passion with
abduction stuff gets views
that's what i like to hear no [ __ ]
that's what i love and that's why i love
joey ladies and gentlemen because you
sit down with colby person you sit down
with mo bradberry
you don't first of all you don't first
never sit down with you
yeah now they hate you okay
but like these guys right they're like
um
they'll be like well i think it's
important i'm trying to inform him i'm
trying to
it's [ __ ] off yeah it's all about the
views thank you for saying that
so you so i've been trying to get ethan
and mo to like interact with them in any
way
possible do they really hate me tell me
about that because you know them right i
haven't talked to them in over a year
though
i mean i talk to them here and there
like very little but uh
i don't know they always play this act
it's kind of funny but then annoying at
the same time where they just pretend
like they don't know what you're talking
about
yep they did that on the phone with you
and yeah they post malone right yep
yeah then that's what they do what they
do that to you i i would be like yo
what's up with all these uh
videos are you dressing up as spiderman
or whatever like what what videos
i'm like dude just like let's do
something funny about it let's let's
make a funny
parody to it he's like what are you
talking about what videos i'm like dude
stop
stop you're like stop stop we're friends
even with you
yeah i literally yeah i can see it's
your house it's your room
it's your [ __ ] play button on the
wall
that's funny because i remember when we
when we like broke i don't know if we
broke it but
we made that video about how they were
doing spider-man elsa
with all their plaques on the wall and i
talked to you about it and you had no
idea they were doing that [ __ ]
yeah i didn't i don't really talk to
them that much like that that i would
know but
um i mean when i saw it i knew it was
them right away
yeah of course yeah so that's funny so i
guess they're
that i always thought like kobe he's
driving all these nice cars
and stuff and i always think like when
he pulls up to a girl
like and they see his gold hundred two
hundred thousand dollar cars like what
does he say like oh what do you do for
work
he's like what does he say at that point
like do kids parties i do kids bodies
that's brilliant that's probably what he
said seriously tell me more about what
you do
don't worry about that baby
i film ethan bradberry ass up and i
think i'm pretty sure they hate me
they kind of scare me ethan bradberry
scares me is he dangerous in your
opinion
no they're very they're very nice moe i
can tell is the nice he's a nice guy he
tries to take care of his insane brother
well eat then he tries to yeah
that's why i bought you that you always
like sometimes you catch him off guard
and like he's like normal but then when
you see she's like
ethan bradberry yeah ethan so it's like
it's like
he'll make like a like a face it's like
a kanye west
yeah yeah 100
have you seen the sunset park stuff
what's that oh
you're in for a wild ride my boy pull up
pull up okay so for those they are
uninitiated
we're talking about the infamous
pranksters ethan and mo bradberry who
have
since the beginning of time made some of
the worst horrible
uh shitty pranks on youtube that we've
always made fun of them like for example
they pioneered the pranks in the hood
where they would go like prank black
people specifically because
isn't that wild and wacky to bring black
people
and anyway since then they've evolved
into doing spider-man and elsa videos
where they dressed up as spider-man and
elsa for kids
um and then now that that they did like
weird sexual spider-man elsa videos
and now that that's a dead meme they've
moved on to something really spicy and
wild
called sunset park we haven't talked
about this too much
but seeing as joey's been with them for
a long time i think it'd be interesting
to get his reaction
on it these are like 25 year old
pranksters like these guys been around
boy
okay and joey's been with them since the
game
[Music]
is it good is it full screen oh god do
you need to full screen
or how does it look on the stream um
yeah it was full screen yeah okay cool
do you need to full screen it or they
can do it
uh i do need to full screen okay cool
okay
all right so yeah all right play that
[ __ ] by eat
come on brother it's about that at least
[Music]
i love that even here they like can't
handle ethan [ __ ]
they're like come on ethan dude it just
looks like
like i would be typing in the comments
even make a video on this like
after you make a video on this i'm not
sure how to approach it but it's weird
because they're like 24-25 and these
kids on the bottom
are 15. yeah they live in a house
together is that true
yeah yes yeah yeah i know what they're
trying to well they're not [ __ ] and
it's kind of like a good business
exactly that's that's what we always say
about them like they're kind of smart
it's like a good business move but like
i feel like they're forcing themselves
in it
yeah like you know like just do your own
thing be behind the scenes don't even
let people know you created sunset cars
they really don't fit in there no kobe's
got kind of this boy george look too and
it's like doug
hey that's you so so should i keep
playing you want to watch more
so anyway the premise is we don't need
to watch the whole thing but the premise
is there in a house
i love this cut after the song and then
[Music]
[Laughter]
they all make their own personal video
and then once a week they make a group
challenge
yeah it's a lot of fun sunset park and
they all fight
yeah joey's already thinking joey's
scheming in his head
so that's it yeah i was really curious
about them because i did
like you notice i spoke to ethan and mo
bradbury on the phone
and they're like i don't know who that
is yeah even though
they just made a video where they said
death to h3h3
like in their one of their spider-man
elsi yeah
they had some balls throwing that in
there right
but then they're going to [ __ ] deny
my existence it's like let's chat why
it's funny to me that they wouldn't even
admit to you i don't know
they make it like it's so obvious it
must be really shameful for them they
stick to the act like are they
embarrassed is it just like a real deep
shame embarrassment
it could be maybe they just didn't know
how to handle like telling me
um like i don't know i was really bad
you're like dude i put my dick in a hot
dog yeah like you can tell me anything
how do you think they're going to feel
about your relationship with them after
this
i don't know yeah your meeting with the
enemy
they'll probably still deny it they're
like you're like
like you're just on a show talking to
the wall yeah what was that that was a
weird really weird man
that was a really weird one who who of
the pranksters you're friends with twins
tv right
yeah those guys are your dogs yeah yeah
let me see
how they doing because they were they
were in pretty deep like
bike pranks that was their hots yeah i
think i don't really know i haven't
talked to them in a few days i saw
something on their channel that they
weren't doing bait pranks anymore i
don't know if you've seen it
i never really watch youtube videos i
think they do vlogs now
yeah they're moving towards vlogs which
is like kind of a safer road to go with
the
whole monetization thing but i mean i
don't know
i like those bait pranks those are great
yeah although they were fake right
i can't say anything about that
confirmed it's all
no no like definitely like shocks on the
bike seats look real to me
like yeah people definitely took a spill
it's kind of like in some of like
uh old octv videos sometimes they
actually did get hit
you can tell like this people are
definitely wiping out
but you know i think everybody knows
nowadays 99.9
of pranks on the internet are fake 99.9
that doesn't leave much room
yeah there's not much room at all and it
yeah i mean like
it goes without saying like just watch a
prank watch her for enjoyment
it's funny it's not i don't care if you
want to be one of those people that are
complaining oh this is fake stupid fake
like
dude everything you watch on the
internet is probably fake yeah and
television
yeah oh and television 100 like reality
tv they call it really
reality tv that's the most fakest of all
the shows i really respect that stance
because on one hand
like first of all the content you're
making like okay just to give you guys
some perspective joey
made a new abduction prank on youtube it
got
it's like 800 800 on facebook i just
checked it at like 120
million yeah that's like gangnam style
views boy
right yeah three three million three
million shares
of this i mean in my my opinion like a
very
very obvious fake abduction break but
we've been around for a long time but my
point is
on facebook you can come here and be
like yes i'm just making entertainment
people on facebook don't see that they
don't people on facebook are catching on
especially when whenever i have a viral
video i don't know check the interview
views on the one the interview you did
with me check the views on that
and try to link it with my viral videos
because people would start tweeting that
to me and putting that in the comments
yeah it's like whenever i have a video
to do good people
always bring that back up again so i
think they're they're typing my name
in and you're probably number one yeah
type joey salads on youtube that can't
be number one still
no i don't think it's number one anymore
but it's probably definitely up there
and probably if you click on one of my
videos it's probably in the related
so let's talk about that um
so you made i'll give you guys some
context of what joey's talking about
you made a it's not at all number one
is it on the front our reaction like the
old one
is is that the form but not the
interview how about that
um so joey made this i think it's
because i've been
double tagging like hardcore my videos
with the joey salads tags
so this way i could push yours down i
think i removed the
[Music]
the tag the tag yeah thank you for that
help her brother out if i can but
youtube's been doing plenty of work to
keep our videos
out of the spotlight anyway so joey made
a prank
um a prank video experiment social
experiment excuse me
such a more dignified title where
you you put a trump car into a
i'll i'll explain it yeah why don't you
explain okay so basically what i did was
i made like a whole social experiment
try to make it put make it political and
i'm like hey
black people hate trump uh and i would
probably say a large majority of them do
um but i was like let's see how they
react to a trump car
parked and then i paid a bunch of people
african-american people to destroy the
car and it was like a street fighter
bonus level
yeah ridiculous it was always like i'm
gonna walk out of frame
and then all of a sudden it's like five
minutes like pipes
and [ __ ] and it's like it's the dumbest
thing wait you didn't provide all that
stuff they went around it wasn't
yeah they had it bring your pipes guys
yeah you're a job creator oh yeah no how
much did you pay
uh i don't remember if i just said zero
yeah
not a job paid one of them i paid one of
the havoc i had one of them that rallied
them all
how much did you pay the ring master i
do not remember
like how much do you usually pay people
to be in your pranks
hunty when it's like um let me just say
this uh
now because i know we're getting i'm
going to talk to fake territory
um not everything i do is fake 99.9
percent
a majority of them i would say i don't
know if there's any videos that after
that there's still a 0.1
but i just have to say is when you're
watching a video
just watch it with the notion of this is
probably most likely fake but it
also might not be because i do have some
real ones out there but you would never
know because
there there's also fake ones in there um
so you really want to know which ones
are real but you would just probably
assume that most of them are fake
like i did the store robbery mostly my
real ones are the ones with the least
amount of views
if that helps you decide which ones are
real
um uh what were we talking about before
that
uh how much i normally pay people yeah
um i normally
let me think i try to get away as low as
i can like i'll start
like i love your honesty i that's why i
love this guy man joey is the [ __ ]
best tell me
i'll start with like a 20. that's 20.
and then i'm like well
is this like a craigslist thing no i
like
i don't go on craigslist and look up to
him so it's like
i don't know so many people get caught
faking their stuff like that where
they're like
i don't know how i don't get how you can
go like the ones the ones that i did do
were that were
uh like the real ones i used this kid
named mike
he's like a young little black kid he's
like 14 i started working with him now
he's 16
i think i found him on craigslist but i
actually used him as like an actor
to set up other people and the videos i
did do with him
were real because i i used him i just
sat in a car and i was like hey just do
this wait for someone
to start asking people to buy you
alcohol and you just ask people i was
waiting in the car for like
two hours until we had enough reactions
um i did a couple videos like that him i
i paid pretty good i think it was like
150 up to 200. yeah yeah
so he's in new york now what's his name
mike shout out to mike yeah shout out to
my guys have been
watching [ __ ] together yeah we've made a
lot of long years yeah god bless mike
but then so usually if you find someone
like for an abduction experiment or
whatever
so how do you find them and then how
does the bidding go on the prices
i'll just put like a friends and family
oh if you got anybody
got it know anybody 20 bucks
i think with the abduction stuff i'm up
my prices i saw at 40.
that's a little more dicey a little more
production value working with miners too
yeah
yeah where do you find that kid because
like that one on facebook that blew up
because you you that was a wonderful
thing when you like took the kid's hand
you're like let's go get some candy like
you were really
convincing yeah i'm not to say which
ones are fake or not
okay let's assume let's pretend as 99.9
are fake so let's pretend that this is
the point one that's not fake
i'm not gonna even pretend it's not fake
i'm just i'm gonna leave it
the people know okay the people already
know okay all right so let me know
let's say you have a kid actor everyone
likes you yeah exactly
if there's a kid actor yeah let me think
where do you find this kid you're like
i'm gonna
abduct you today if i'm gonna need we're
gonna run off there were some
i mean not obviously not all of them but
there were some reactions in
uh let me try to think of one for
example uh another one that went viral
on youtube
i mean facebook did pretty good on
youtube about 20 million on facebook and
like that's crazy i don't have news on
any video we never get that
16 million is the most we've had on vape
nation facebook
views are on another level insane but
the retention rate is like
20 seconds well they cheat the stats
right because if you're like scrolling
well yet they watch for at least three
seconds three seconds
and you can actually even see the stats
how many people clicked on the video to
watch it with
sound the retention rate and you just
see the retention rate like
in the first three seconds it's like up
to like six seconds sometimes and it
just
plummets wow so like youtube's shady
yeah so like uh like that that video um
with 120 million views the retention
time on it is
is i think it was like 25 30 seconds
wow so that's probably pretty good
that's good for facebook yeah that's
good because that
the video is only like a minute long
that's actually probably really good
yeah you got to keep videos on facebook
like
as short as you possibly can and like
hook them in really
quick at first right unless they'll just
keep scrolling so
the the sofa text like on the top and
bottom
did that start because people don't even
turn on the sound on facebook yeah that
that helps a lot like if you're gonna do
facebook videos stop putting things on
the top
and the bottom because when people
stroll they see that if it's like
shocking video or like our fans will
love that someone ran over ran over by
car
people are gonna be like oh wait i gotta
see this you know so i mean like the
very nature of the platform of facebook
just breeds
it's like a [ __ ] ground because
because of like
everyone there has no attention span
yeah no there's zero
license you've got the soflo this did
sofalo invent that
the [ __ ] bars the crying laughing emoji
i don't know if he invented it but
there's
so many facebook pages the first i saw
it's the first time i saw it yeah oh
they don't want to give him too much
credit yeah yeah i don't want to give
him credit for that
but there's so many like facebook pages
that just straight up turned into
companies
do you make money on that 120 million i
make money on facebook
you got into monetization yeah it's like
closed now and it's like if you get in
you got to be like lucky as hell
like really know so i i even tried to
get through like we have some strong
connections and even
like our agency couldn't get us into
facebook monetization it's tough
how much but does that really make you a
lot because i don't that's what i want
to know how
does it find like a big company it's
like a [ __ ] cpm
probably like anywhere from like 100 to
300
every million views but when you get
hundreds of millions of views it adds up
so on 150 million you made like
you gotta i gotta do the calculator like
two
ten thousand twenty thousand probably
more wow
yeah [ __ ] hell it's getting passed
around like dude from one video
yeah i never made that much on one video
holy [ __ ] so is facebook your like
primary source of income oh yeah like i
just got my
my checks from youtube and facebook for
like it's the following month
and my facebook check was literally 10
times higher than
why is facebook not hooking people up
what they're doing is
they're waiting they have like the
people who are in
the beta monetization program on
facebook half are in
the one that i'm in where it's basically
if you click on a video and watch it and
you start scrolling through
it'll be like a sponsored video like in
the video feed
and the other half are in mid-roll ads
you'll see it on very few pages they're
really big ones right yeah those are
juicy heads
and uh like 30 like usually halfway
through the video it plays an ad
which is i don't know how it keeps
people even watching that's what i'm on
especially
not a lot of people must yeah but i mean
i've seen the numbers and the stats on
the money generated from those videos
you know people who are in that
yeah and i've seen them like wow i'm
like amazed at people do you know what's
the cpm on that kind of on that kind of
program i would have to look through my
my messages and do the math i don't
really know but it's much better than
then yeah and then eventually i'm sure
they can have to have them combined and
it'll just be triple
i don't know what because i know like
you're always getting into these weird
programs [ __ ] like i remember you were
trying to
help me get twitter monetization a while
ago yeah and i know like really big
channels like really big channels that
don't have facebook
monetization and they have like 100
millions of views every month
bigger than youtube and they can't even
yeah it's like i i mean how do you get
into that [ __ ] who's dick who's what
who's dick who's hot dog bun don't you
put my dick it's it's all about who you
know and
i run my social medias like at the end
of the day
my videos are mostly cringe and they
kind of suck
for the most part i would say so god
bless um
some of the content i make i actually do
enjoy and i like and i'm like i had fun
doing that
um but the majority i don't even think
is that good but i run it like a
business
i have deals here deals there to boost
stuff to make sure i could monetize
everything
to get the most out of each video as i
possibly can
make the connections and facebook the
facebook people they're the ones that
know everybody and that could
link you and connect you with you know
twitter stuff instagram stuff
uh even snapchat stuff you mean
employees of facebook or
the marketers the the yeah the the
marketers i would say the the people who
run the big accounts
and there they they usually and
everything's like
they all work on referral stuff so like
i know like say if i know one person
person a
and he's working with person b person b
created this new monetization thing or
he has the plug in facebook for
monetization he goes person hey yo
find people to sign up and i'll give you
like 20
of whatever they make and then that
person a will just
reach out i'll be one of those people
and be like yo if you got anyone else
any friends of yours that want to be in
as well you know send them
send them my way i'm like alright cool i
usually like hooking people up like i
even tried to hook up keemstar
as just like like good faith
type stuff like yo like let's put the
youtube stuff behind us all the beefing
on youtube
all the [ __ ] talking and i'll help you
out i'll do something for you you know
like i see you're struggling on youtube
maybe down the road one day
something will come up where it would
you would help me out because i helped
you out
so that's why i do it i try to hook up
all my friends into all these programs
and stuff like
um this guy i know his name uh i might
even say his name but he
created a system on facebook that they
can monetize any video
through call to action links so on
facebook if you go and you see like an
ad and you click on the video sometimes
below the video it brings into like a
website
um what happened was he uh created like
a system and an algorithm to put
that stuff on like any video like would
be your video i think i tried to
hook you up on it wait how does that
work does it's not through facebook
it's through facebook but it's like
through an algorithm
that would like take your video and put
it in like a paid promotion
for like pennies and it would put a
website on the bottom of the website
would be
just ads and uh then
after that uh you know it's on your page
and now it has ads on it and it'll be
hooked up to like a system
and the video the money generated on the
website will go right to your account
so that was a system that worked great
for a few weeks and i was
able to get people in like a
monetization program they weren't able
to do it through facebook
but of course soflo came in and started
spamming it to hell wow where you would
go and watch your video and like you
just
add blasting on top of your video from
the website
and it was like sub flow rooms yeah
yeah single-handedly ruined that so now
facebook shut the whole thing down any
video that had it got deleted
so i lost like half my videos any video
with it got deleted
yeah it sounded and then some people's
accounts got totally outright banned
wow so flow of course was fine this is
why i hate facebook
for many reasons i'm just gonna be real
here it's just so shady it's a shitty
shady [ __ ] hole
shitty shady and when you bro first of
all you browse that food and it's just
garbage it's like being [ __ ] on your
face and then someone puking on it
doesn't make sense to me just a bunch of
crap and videos and spam
it's like uh it's incoherent it's so
much stuff just reposted as well
yeah it's like my videos get reposted by
random pages all the time and i'm just
be scrolling about oh there's my video a
huge
organization it's like a huge orgy of
copyright and the only person who
benefits is facebook and they don't give
a [ __ ]
and now some companies they they reach
out to me now because i
i'm like at that point where i'm big
enough you know they usually take
smaller people's stuff without even
composting no credit because what are
they going to do so they've been asking
me
and i'd be like all right so i always
try to work out deals all right if you
post my stuff if you're monetized i want
to do a revenue share split or
we can cross post from my page so the
revenue goes some weird
stuff and some of the companies have
been lying to me saying oh we don't make
money on our videos we would just like
to post it
i've been told that too but yeah and
then i'll be like okay post it i'm like
wait these people is no way
they've run a hundred accounts they're
blasting out getting hundreds of
millions of views full-time employees
like okay
employees i'm like so i reached out
people i know and i found out yeah they
are making money
so then i yeah so i tell them like don't
post my stuff facebook's just full of
scammers yeah
and it it it just it's just the place
for scams yeah
it's just they enable them and then this
is what
[ __ ] pissed me off you have a page
like soflo who from the beginning
his whole point was stealing people's
videos he was one of the first people
with monetization
one of the very first pages with
monetization ripping other people's [ __ ]
off
nothing ever happened to soflo he even
when we made a parody facebook page
i don't know if you remember that we
made a video yeah so we made
this is how [ __ ] shady he's got to do
that manually
so he went on and he did it but they had
a complaint
so we made um we made a parody of
soflo's facebook page a video
and we made a page called self flow bro
where i was ripping off soflo's videos
and posting them there as a parody
and so soflo followed a complaint with
facebook saying that we were
impersonating him
and not only did they close our page but
they took all of our followers
and made them follow soflo's page these
are all people who hate soflo who are
fans of ours who like this page just to
meme on him
and then they tense yeah tens of
thousands of people and they made them
all like soflo
can you imagine that did you ever get
your page back or no yeah yeah we got it
back
and also only after making a whole video
about it yeah yeah probably so many
complaints and facebook is probably like
let's just make it wrong
but they're untouchable it makes me
[ __ ] happy yeah what happens is there
are corrupt people
at each single social media in youtube
twitter facebook instagram snapchat
there are those few people that are in
there
that are pretty much corrupt mm-hmm it's
almost like i want to get kickbacks like
under the table yeah
it's like i want to know these people i
know so many people
who have uh instagram accounts that only
post copyrighted stuff they get deleted
the channels but you don't make money on
instagram no but at least that
they make money on it because they post
like ads and stuff very spammy very bad
they got millions of followers
they have like integrated like people
pay them directly to post
garbage and their pages get deleted all
the time
like all the time like two three times a
month sometimes
but they know somebody on instagram like
throwing 500 bucks get my page back no
way
that's going to be so transparent so
yeah that's like that on every every
social media youtube as far as i can
tell they're because google is like i
met a ton of higher ups at youtube
recently because we went to the creator
summit
and these people are like they're all
like real
team players i don't know yeah you think
they're like there's definitely some in
there like they
i mean they they they do favor they
definitely favor and do shady [ __ ] for
sure
yeah i mean like i watched but they just
blame the algorithm
yeah that's the big scary like i was
watching
the only thing i watch on youtube or
other podcasts like
probably like two times a week um
but i was watching stephen crowder i
don't know if you've heard of him he's
like he's like you know this is a
republican he does
podcasts uh yeah kind of young guy yeah
yeah i know the guy i was just watching
i was watching about the yeah the bill
and i thing
yeah he does some stuff too about like
the youtube monetization stuff and like
the young turks like they're like
made a video you know what something
stupid and they had it featured on do
you know what's trending now that's
[ __ ]
true first of all let me just say for
the record i'm not a conservative person
i'm not
i'm not conserving it at all but when we
went to the creator summit the young
turks they were there
they featured him they even put him in
one of the presentations he interviewed
they're a meme now they're a joke like
the young turks yeah
the most of their stuff just gets
debunked right away by other republican
podcasts or like they're seen as like
the hypocrisy like sometimes their
arguments like it just goes so far
left where a lot of people on the left
side are like dude this is too much
i haven't seen that stuff but the one
thing i did see of theirs when
this [ __ ] oh my god this [ __ ] made me
angry seinfeld is my favorite show of
all time
and they did this segment about jerry
seinfeld was on
larry king and larry king didn't know
that um seinfeld didn't cancel that
larry king thought that seinfeld was
kind of cbs
canceled seinfeld which is honestly one
of the dumbest things you can say
especially when you're interviewing
jerry seinfeld the show was number one
it's the most popular show of all time
it still gets 100 million dollar deals
oh god yeah dude they're bill
larry david is a billionaire just from
syndication regard so
larry king doesn't know this and jerry's
like do you not know this he gave him
some [ __ ]
and i think fully justifiably so they
did a clip about this and this
the main girl there she's like who is
jerry seinfeld anyway i think he's just
bought her that nobody remembers who he
is
and i was like [ __ ] who the [ __ ] are
you
this is jay sci i don't know that [ __ ]
wrote me wrong i never forgot that did
you see the clip with
alex jones when he crashed their thing
yeah that's
oh man cause the young turks they lost
their [ __ ] yeah that was well i lost it
you're you're a real conservative guy
yeah i've been trying to stay away from
it but like keeps pulling me back in
well you're
on you're active yeah it's like no it's
like weird like if you watch look at my
twitter it's like i'll have like
two weeks of non-stop republican talk
and then i'll just go like two weeks
like you just
see me post like a video of like
something on that posted on facebook
and then i go get sucked back into it
i'm just like trying to like just live
my life like i hate
reading about it i definitely try my
best never to touch politics but i'm
fascinated by your involvement because
like a lot of your pranks seem to be
very
from a perspective right from a very
specific
political perspective for example the
trump car and the black neighborhood
your theory was that black people hate
trump yeah so like
uh going back to the whole uh social
experiment thing and
politics and stuff i'll occasionally now
do a political social experiment but i'm
consciously
like anything you see me do political
now is a hundred percent
real i'm not stepping on that foot again
where i'm doing a fake social experiment
i went to sweden i made like a 25-minute
documentary i saw that it was
i went in there and p and i didn't even
go i went there and i was like i'm gonna
make the most non-biased thing i could
possibly make i'm just going to
interview people i'm just going to walk
around whatever i get
i get i'm going to put in there and i
showed two both sides of the story
and that's it i didn't even give any of
my opinion on anything what was your
what were you looking like what was your
theory about sweden
uh i mean like trump uh made the
comments about sweden saying
um what happened last night in sweden
you know the migrants are coming in the
crime's going up
and you know i i took what he said i'm
like okay you know i see what he said i
believe that
yeah i believe that i went in i did my
research i'm like okay would he
which city did you did add up i was in
stockholm
um and then i went to i think it was
like in stockholm it's like rink b
and uh a couple other times i forget the
names and then
sweetie so what did you find there yeah
so yeah so when i went there i was like
let's go there and let's see who's right
is trump right or is the left mainstream
media right
about everything i went there and it was
like an extreme split
of like trump versus the left yeah that
is complete
opposite because whatever they say
they'll go against something in the
middle right yeah so
i went there and i interviewed my
friends that i knew there
um nobody wanted to be on camera it's
like i had
i had the blur out everybody's face
nobody
like even me walking around with a
camera they were making sure i weren't
on it or like when you talk politics no
one wants to be on it because it's like
if you get caught talking out about the
refugees and the migrant crisis then you
lose your job you'll lose everything
but what i found is there trump was
right because i go there
and i'm i'm talking to people and the
people who were
willing to come out and talk about you
know the migrant situation they would
they said they're like yeah they're like
i used to live in this really nice
neighborhood and these no-go zones
which sometimes cops do patrol and they
call them no-go zones because cops don't
patrol there but sometimes they actually
do so i found that out
it's not completely a no-go zone but
that's just what everyone refers to them
because it's very low
place activity there because um like
i went to spots where all the riots are
breaking out um one thing that i could
debunk
that the right was saying is uh there
was a lot of car explosions
that happened like there was one time
where a whole parking lot got lit on
fire
and they were the right some people on
the right were saying oh it's terrorism
terrorism terrorism you see because
they're muslims i don't even say the
word muslim once in my entire video
well it's obvious i i didn't even want
to make it about a religion thing i was
just making it
solely based of migrants like not even
like motorcycles but what i found out
was
with the car stuff um they were doing it
for insurance
it was swedish people no no it was the
migrants
but it wasn't an act of terror it was
not an act of terror
it was they would all get together
calling each other up i was talking to a
migrant that told me this he's like yeah
i came here in the 80s you know
i moved up in society everything's nice
and dandy but he's like these stupid
some of these migrants coming in now
it's all punks they're all gang members
they're coming in they're just starting
a whole heap of mess a whole heap of
problems they're
attacking cops and what they do is they
all get all their cars together some
nights
and they just blow them all up they have
grenades he says because they
i guess when they come up or they
smuggle in like weapons like
actual weapons and he says they they
blow it up to collect money from the
insurance
i'll tell you we were interested yeah we
weren't just there and the comments were
[ __ ] horrifying there were so
many racist shitty comments like um
like just to give you an idea stuff like
um don't let ella get raped
by the uh the refugees or whatever right
like that's the meme
and if you look at it it's really
shocking well let me tell you because i
don't
i had no idea where it came from like we
just posted vlogs and all of a sudden
all the comments were like about that
yeah i was pretty horrified but i'll
tell you we were in stockholm
for a week we walked around there at
three in the morning several times three
five six in the morning
i never i didn't once feel unsafe yeah
it's not i mean
it's it's kind of at the same time was
the left side of the argument is
you know you got nice cities like la but
if you go to the wrong side of the town
you're going to get la is way sketchier
than
stockholm yeah like downtown in l.a yeah
it all depends on
what areas you go to of anywhere there's
going to be crime you know
but the problem is is this is like
imported crime like um the sweden's
statistics on anything crime related is
skewed
and almost fraudulent in most cases
because
uh the police don't like to report on
certain things so what is your theory
why do you
think that the swedish government itself
wants it
because the way you point it out is
almost like the swedes
want to be victimized because they don't
want to report it
they don't want to acknowledge it it's
that's a little deeper i don't really
know much of what the theory is they
just want they just keep doubling down
on bringing more and more migrants in
they're like there's something wrong
well
let's put this into perspective in
america there's
over i think 300 million people in
sweden i believe there's only like
nine about yeah about nine and i i
i don't remember my numbers are not 100
correct but i remember i did the math
and last year with the migrants that
they
brought in the refugees is like adding
an
entire los angeles yeah that makes sense
to america
do you acknowledge that sweden is doing
like a good thing for the world
because these the syrian refugees are
being like bombed and gassed and
yeah i mean it it's definitely like you
you need to do something
but at the same time as i don't think
you should bring that from
a third world country to a first world
country it doesn't mix
and it and what happening is the zones
that they're living in is expanding
and it's it's merging into actually the
nice zones so it's like you say you take
compton
and say every year compton expands a
mile closer to the city
that's exactly what's happening in
sweden they're nice their nice cities
are getting smaller
their bad cities are getting bigger and
it's because of the influx i wonder what
a swede would tell
yeah if they're here right now did you
get any kickback from the swedes after
you made your documentary
um a lot tim poole he's a a journalist
who went there and he basically
uncovered
pretty much the same exact thing i did
but he's a conservative guy he's not
even a conservative guy
he's just he's just a journalist he goes
out there um
and he pretty much uncovered the same
exact thing and we even got pulled over
by the cops we were driving through um
a no-go zone and the cops pulled us over
they took us out of the car
they're like what are you doing here
they're like oh we're just filming
documentaries they're like get out of
here you're not prepared for what these
people would do to you
if they see you filming i just
i the thing that doesn't make sense to
me in this like
this narrative is like i says why do the
swedes want to be victimized and
and [ __ ] over and taken advantage of
and not report the stats not acknowledge
it
um they have like i've interviewed one
guy
and what he does is all that he does is
he just gathers statistics on news
stories or stuff that goes on in sweden
and he has a whole column and a whole
category for
hand grenade attacks that the police try
to ignore
uh example why did the police try to
ignore hand grenade attacks does it make
any
what happens but why what's your theory
i don't even i don't even know how can
you hold this opinion and not have any
like theory about what
it seems like an insane thing to do
right it's got to be a good reason yeah
i mean
i used to have theories but i went so
long ago and i tried not to think about
it let me
try to think so i think basically
um their government is super leftist
spokes right yeah you can say it
cucks i don't even use that word when
i'm talking
politics inside i just think it's stupid
like because everyone like
people call me cuck everyone gets called
a cuck it's stupid
okay and uh so i think that because
they're leftists they want to prov their
idea the ideology is providing for the
world
and or their country everything free
everything for everybody everyone lives
very socially in a utopia very socialist
and what happens is they're trying to
aid these migrants
which i remember seeing a video on
youtube of a guy showing like
um this is what happens when you bring a
refugee in you know you let's say
first world countries bring like two
million in there's three million
created so you're not at the end like
when you look at the whole scale of
everything
uh between you know how many migrants
you're bringing in you're not even
making a dent in the numbers
like america like you bring in 100 000
out of you know tens of millions
there's this one saying what is it i
think it's a jewish saying when you save
one life you save the whole world or
something i think that was muslim
is it everyone just wants to claim that
[ __ ] yeah give it to him well it makes
more sense in that context
yeah i'll give it to the muslims um
but like so i i when we did the fan
meetup i met the syrian refugee he came
and it had it actually had an impact on
me mm-hmm yeah he came to our friend
yeah um i actually when i went
in the migrant zones i actually got
recognized by a couple years really
yeah and i told them i was like hey i
want to interview you about what's going
on in your town
and uh she told me she's like yeah you
know it's very bad you know
she was basically telling me confessing
everything that happens you know the
gangs run rampant at night you know it's
really bad
i'm like okay let me get you on a skype
interview and interview you oh no no i
said too much i can't talk to you
anymore and i was actually
supposed to meet up with a few other
people i guess there were
young men on there and then she warned
me she's like i know those kids
they're planning on uh they might be
planning on jumping you at the place
you're trying to meet them at
so i had to cancel that because i was
going to interview more people there
that would willing to do it but the
this girl told me be careful they might
jump you so i canceled it
um yeah i'm conflicted on it i mean
obviously
i didn't really investigate it i don't
know my anyway we
we had the fan meet up and a really tall
spoke really good english arab-looking
guy he's like i just moved here a year
and a half ago from syria
and um he was just telling me about how
like sweden saved his life because his
whole [ __ ] block was [ __ ]
and i never i don't think i've ever met
a syrian refugee that was the first time
yeah but he's like i used to watch your
videos
when i was in syria and we were getting
bombed
yeah it was shocking i was like what and
he said a bunch of syrians
he knew back in during that time you
should watch our videos
see like a misconception with the right
is people are like oh you don't want to
take refugees in you want them all to
die you don't want to do anything for
them
which is the very opposite because it's
no uh the people on the right want to
enact policies and
help them out over there basically fix
let's fix the problem there to make it
better for everybody
that's what the rights proposal is i
guess that's like
the left is just let them all come in
here even though i don't think that's
true not not all of them
that's a very oversimplification of what
the left
i think want to do just let them in
that's not what's happening in most
places in europe for example
floodgates i know like in america the
policy of like vetting
refugees is pretty pretty tough it takes
like a couple of years
it's not just like get on a boat let's
go y'all no and i think in germany
they all just walked up there it's true
it's a lot less
they're also a lot closer but they're
right there and they're [ __ ] dying
they're they're literally getting bombed
and and slammed on
so it's a bruh it's very it's it's
definitely a tough decision because
you know radical extremists are using
that as a
walkway just to get up through and see
again this is this is another contested
point like
i don't know i'm not deep enough into
all the stats and stuff but i think that
like the amount of terrorists they're
purportedly like
snuck in is probably not as big as the
alarmists say
yeah i mean i'm always open to the
possibility like i don't know like my
most extreme side of my thinking is like
i just feel like one day they're all
just going to start flooded in through
those
and it's like flooding in through what
through the migrant stream oh yeah i
mean it makes sense and just
start like deploying in all over the
country and now they're
they're everywhere and they're all
communicating with each other next thing
you know they set a full-scale attack
and like wreak some havoc on one day
that's like my worst side of thinking
that's going to happen that
is ridiculous though it is the level of
coordination
like it would be crazy it was uh
um the movie would i think was drawed
butler
well they're not like an army let's just
say that's right they're just like
rogue animals like but here's the i
think just creating a bomb and
or running people over with a car the
thing i think the best way i've heard it
explain
i don't remember who it was um but it's
like a it's a war of ideas right
like i don't think it's even an issue of
letting people in
or keeping people out of money too
okay but it's like you know just like
from a moralistic
standpoint it's a good thing to do right
but it's not even about like
bringing letting terrorists intelligent
people it's a war of ideas like you need
to
you need them the muslims who know which
is the vast majority
that you're not supposed to blow [ __ ] up
right the the ones who observe it as
it's supposed to be observed and not
want to kill people
to like be on your side you have to like
the norm in the culture needs to be hey
[ __ ] these guys who are blowing up
kindergarten and schools and stuff so
you need to you need to like be
it's a word
i have tons of muslim friends i know
that
yeah i know there are some really the
majority of the muslims i would say are
like
really nice good people like you and me
like they don't
believe in that bombing stuff but
there's there's still
i remember i forgot what the number i
forgot where the numbers came from but
there's like
well over 100 million muslims who do
support isis
i've seen some stats like that and it's
scary it is scary well the thing how
many muslims are in the world there's
like billions it's the most it's the
biggest religion the biggest religion
but like um i have seen some [ __ ] like
again i don't know if it's true but if
it is it's very alarming uh some study
that was like ten percent of all muslims
in england want sharia law or some
[ __ ] so it could be prophetically
they have sharia law courts and stuff
and sharia law depends on what kind of
shrill
you look at i mean there are some
versions of sharia law where it's okay
to beat your wife
it's okay to kill someone who's not a
muslim
and that's like i feel like to me as an
israeli
it seems so weird that people here are
so concerned with these
issues like you're in america you're so
far from everyone
yeah and down there it's like seems a
little paranoid israel is actually
surrounded by countries who want
everyone dead
yeah yeah so like when i'm here and i
hear all these people so concerned about
it i'm like what are you even talking
about
yeah like you're safe up here yeah i
mean it's a good point
it's a good point it's like it doesn't
even seem like i mean
compared to israel it seems like there's
not even a problem here
it's a good point it's like israel is
like are you taking a little too
seriously like why is it so personally
affecting you yeah in the way that it
seems like maybe it's selfish
or like an overreaction or more like the
overreaction or it's like you know
it's this classical thing of like um
this the scapegoat right like [ __ ] these
arabs or
these muslims or whatever yeah it's like
this classical scapegoat because it's
almost like not even really a problem in
america
at all like on on scale yeah israel
when ila was a kid they were blowing up
cafes like every weekend right yeah
and hila's and she has a really good
point he's like i don't worry about
getting blown up cafes
a lot of people they're like it's
clearly like
all their attacks all their wars it's an
ideology
based religion based attack
it's all based on islam it's not like
they needed money and they wanted to
steal some bread and they blew up the
shop
like no it's all based on the ideology
and the scaring thing is
i mean every single religion there's bad
stuff in each religion
but example is if if you look at islam
and you start reading through the quran
there's a lot of probably a lot worse
stuff in there i don't know
the bible and torah are [ __ ] whack
there is some older christians
the jews they did terrible the crusade
the difference through reformations
yeah that's the difference that's the
difference right that's the difference
because we have like a hierarchy
structure of our church system
where they're like okay this is bad like
killing someone they all agree
that's why i say it's like a war of
ideas in a way because i do on the other
hand acknowledge that like
i think per capita a lot of the weird
[ __ ] terrorism and crimes and [ __ ] i
mean there's definitely
some strong thread of violence through
that muslim community or arab muslims to
be more specific
so the extreme that like there's a
really extremist
like you hear people say like you don't
see jews and christians going and
[ __ ]
doing suicide bombs maybe you do see
some christians these days
there's been some weird like alt-right
terrorists yeah
a lot of those are false flags like the
new one that they're labeling
this guy he like stabbed somebody i
didn't even read too much into it
but basically they labeled him as an
alt-right extremist who stabbed someone
based off of whatever their religion or
color i forgot what it was he didn't
even vote for trump
yeah and he was a bernie supporter and
was like well i think that's fine
it's a problem with the world today
everybody like wants to use
everything sometimes [ __ ] just happens
whatever happened to just being a crazy
person
wants to kill people exactly it's not
like everything's a race
or religion yeah everybody wants to use
every situation to further
their narrative and it's it's it's
[ __ ] up but that's why i mean
like it's a war of ideas for me yeah
because like
inside the muslim arab community i feel
like you have to
you have to um connect
with the vast majority of sane good
loving people
so that they all can den we can all
denounce these it's like
it's like entire countries where they're
just brainwashing all their children at
a young age
you know this is this is our god this is
our religion you know
it says here you have to do this if
someone does this you
you know um they castrate like women
yeah mutilate genitals like very like
yeah there's some [ __ ] primitive
primitive stuff yeah
i saw an ad i don't know if you guys saw
this it was [ __ ]
it moved me dude some telecom um company
god what was the kind i don't remember
the country but it was a arabic ad from
a muslim country
strike that reverse it whatever and um
it was like this really moving thing
about how they were like
saying no to terrorists and [ __ ] and
humiliating
i have no idea where we saw it i saw it
on reddit
but it was like this huge telecom uh
company made this for ramadan it was
like
all these people okay like this i'd read
a yeah
it was really moving so this one guy was
like trying to blow [ __ ] up
and all these normal people were like
coming together to be like [ __ ] you
loser in a much more poetic way yeah but
that's the kind of thing that i love
seeing from from them where i'm like oh
god this is what i think is wonderful
what i personally think is to fix the
problem is for all muslims especially
very vocal ones that have
an influence in the muslim community
just come out and basically
be open and honest like how i am about
any religion like i'm a christian born
and raised christian but i know there's
some stuff
in there that's messed up but as a
christian i'm only following
the set of guidelines of being a good
person you know
basically how like jesus is the model as
like a perfect human being live the life
without sin no bad things whatever
the end of the day i don't even believe
in it i just believe in
any religion that's just teachings
whether it's real or not
it's a gazillion religions odds of ours
being right is
slim to none but i just like to see it
as a way of teaching
but i feel like muslims and people who
study the quran should just be open like
yeah
muhammad did this he did this bad thing
he did this bad thing but we're going to
just ignore that
and let's just focus on the good things
and that teaching
but i haven't seen not one come out and
just have an open discussion about that
like it's an undeniable fact where if
you're in a debate and you're prepared
to
denounce stuff in in the quran and
you've got the verses out in front of
you you can just say a ton of stuff
and they'll just definitely wish we had
a muslim person here to speak me too
speak for it i remember because we're
just kind of circle jerky yeah i
remember i don't really know what we're
talking about i think
fouseytube was actually confronted
multiple times about stuff
that muhammad did you know by raping
like a six-year-old or something like
that and he would just ignore it or
or not even defend it just like kind of
like brush over it
like why don't you like that's an
undeniable fact that's in your book
why don't you address it and have a
solution to what you're addressed like
you're
it's like how can you address that i
don't know it's like i'm sure that
you know being muslim it's um
i'm sure that like you can you can be
muslim as like a culture
and not necessarily like orthodox
muslim it's the same in israel yeah yeah
so
it's like how can you address it i don't
know he's a muslim in his identity
i don't i'd like to hear it not
necessarily about this one story about
one guy
yeah i don't know yeah from someone came
up to me like hey
moses [ __ ] shoved his cane up a
little girl's vag
yeah what do you have to say about that
what well i guess i would be like well
that's
weird but you're still jealous yeah i'm
still doing it
yeah i wonder if moses [ __ ] stuck his
cane up any
if he did any weird stuff with his
camera he definitely did some weird [ __ ]
turned it into a snake
it's a different time yeah the different
differences
here's this ad i want to show you guys i
think this is it yeah i think this is it
i'm glad we got the cnn money stamp oh
yeah
confront your enemy with peace not war
so
yeah you guys you guys can watch the
[ __ ] video
worship your guard with love i guess
it's for the people who can't see it
this movie was launched in may
yada yada yeah the problem with this is
there's a whole section of
muslims watching this and they're like
if you stop that guy from blowing up
those non-muslims you're not really a
muslim
like all the muslims living in america
well clearly that's not
that's not made for people who are the
audience yeah no
of course but like say uh if we had a
muslim in this room right now just
talking to us
there's a whole section of islam who
like that person's not
a real muslim i'm not going to because
these people's mouths
well you can say that about any
relationship yeah we'll talk to an
orthodox guy he's going to say
it's not a real dream because she
doesn't cover her hair when she goes out
yeah yeah well it sounds the same
it sounds like their version is a lot
more extreme
than ours for sure because relationship
because you disagree they're the worst i
don't know i don't even know much about
the jewish culture if you want to talk
about like terrible yeah
they're not perfect there was a an
orthodox guy who went on a stabbing
spree at the
jerusalem pride parade last year the
last year oh they're the worst also in
israel we
have we have purim which is the holiday
where you wear
costumes like like the same that you
have here kind of
so um one time i just wore like
i don't even know like maybe shorts or a
skirt or something
not even like crazy i don't wear like
[ __ ]
yeah stuff and there's plenty of people
who i i was just revealing some skin and
some orthodox guys started to curse me
for work i was just walking the streets
i went to uh an islamic country recently
i can't say who
what country weird reasons why i can't
say
where i was how bad could it be you
can't say the country i always told
you that i was told this is like one of
the most advanced
islamic countries socially and most
acceptable
muslim countries there was some nice
place why can't you say the country i'm
fascinated by that
the more i'll i'll tell you all there
god
but like can you hint that's so weird
i'm not gonna give a hint
um but basically joey got into some
trouble
did you get in trouble i didn't really
get in trouble but i would get in
trouble okay um
basically i went there with the notion
everyone on the trip was saying this is
the most
you know advanced islamic country super
social there were
some really beautiful parts of the
country i'll give them that but the
majority of it
like the women were told when you go out
into this
into the city into the streets cover up
like how much
because even if i don't show any skin
like we were with a girl
who would a girl who had her her uh her
legs showing like half of her legs shown
everybody in their mothers were staring
at her okay and
yeah i mean like you can wear you don't
have to wear like a full thing like you
like i've seen like even in iran and
lebanon they were like
gotta wear a full thing so that's not
the most liberal
muslim yeah it i mean it could be but
it's still like
it's not an iran and lebanon on the two
that i know you have to
you don't oh you do you have to wear it
but you can like show
yeah hair still yeah it was the same in
indonesia yeah
yeah you can wear like a mini scarf yeah
and then
upon leaving the trip the women on the
trip were like
this place was a hellhole it sucked like
and they were the ones going in
like talking highly of it and when we
went there
it was a mess like the the country's a
third world country
and so the place you know people there
and you don't want to be saying yeah i
don't want to say
okay um what you were saying
you were saying you disagree with my
point earlier uh because like if i
said a muslim let's just say a terrorist
muslim
would say like say we had um
kareem you know kareem youtuber i can't
know his last name
make social experiments muslims oh yeah
yeah yeah i can't pronounce his last
name i don't even try
um he's watching right now if he was in
this room talking he is
yeah right now yeah cool
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] joey's got this apple
he's like you you guys said you needed a
muslim that could have been me
oh yeah that would have been really yeah
oh you're getting a text to your watch
joey's a high-tech boy
yeah if he was in that room right now
and some other muslim
who's planning to blow up another ariana
grande concert he would say
kareem is not a real muslim and he
deserves to die well sure some
yeah we're talking whole thing yeah
extremists i'm saying is but that's not
i've i've never met or even heard of a
christian extremist
i don't know jewish is enough
christian terrorist the unabomber i
don't know if it was a practicing
christian
what i'm saying is like i don't know of
any christian or even heard of any
incidents or cases or even if there's a
number for it
of christians that would be like me in
this room with with the jew
you deserve to die because you're not a
real christian you're associating with a
jew
like well you know in islam it's
definitely
a larger number and a much harsher
treatment in the case
of that happening okay like i i can't
like if save you went and
would you say you other jewish people
were telling you to cover up and stuff
yeah what would be the punishment i'm
just curious like
no yeah there's no point there's no
punishment well okay
but they'll tell you like you yeah are
not following
the tendencies yeah
i'll definitely i'll definitely agree
with that point where but i don't think
any really
i don't think first of all even
throughout the whole muslim world i
don't think there's many like how do you
call it when you like don't practice
when you give up
secular no there's this name for it like
there's definitely like
i don't know i know you believe the
faith apostate i think it's called
anyway i know so i don't think there's
many
deaths even across the whole globe where
they're like oh you left islam i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you now like
maybe it happens a couple times a year i
don't know yeah i don't even know the
number but regardless
i have one jews are [ __ ] crazy man
there was a prime minister this this
story is great and horrifying both what
was his name the one who was about to
bring peace
robin robin so there was this prime
minister in israel
he had brokered peace between the
palestinians it was like
going to happen and he was assassinated
not by a palestinian but by a extreme
jew wow [ __ ] nothing gunned down
right yeah
at a speech yeah at a speech i think
that all these religions
start all this violence and terrorism i
believe
it's a possibility it could have just
started from aliens flying over
now you're talking at the end of the day
i don't know if you're kidding or not
but i want to explore that it's a
mystery
no one will know unless something freaky
happens
wasn't there an alien ufo flying over la
like just last year
if this wasn't ufo okay here's what i
want to do
here's what i want to say we've talked
enough about this [ __ ] yeah
let's move it on i want to talk about
aliens and i want to talk about ghosts
we have for some reason it's become a
thing where we have ghost stories
i don't know why let's take a quick
break
let's go get let's go hydrate i've been
hydrating this whole time
let's go dehydrated yeah
guys we'll be back in five minutes with
spooks and goofs
and ufos guys welcome back from the
break we are here with joey
saladino and sean
that's pretty good that's close yeah
that's good yeah to the realtors
um you were about to ask joey a question
about his
his uh pranks so we always see posts
like on twitter and facebook nonsense
look who's using my
or my teachers using one of the
saladinos
social experiments in my sociology class
like how do you feel about those fake
videos being featured wow
i think about college courses like
educating the youth it is such a good i
think about that
all the time and i just think to myself
it's all a prank
that's the prank i love that on one hand
you're like
you're super passionate about like this
refugee issue
for like the betterment of society but
on the other hand you have
teachers using your fake experiments in
these classes and you're talking
you're directly eroding the fabric of
society
how do you but like generally like those
two things you made a joke about it i
think i'm sorry
i think it's you know over exaggerating
a little bit
over comparing child abduction uh
in videos of uh
staged instance instances compared to
refugees
i think that's a well one stretch
um so examine the child abduction went
on its own then
so like well you're fear-mongering
though
i would say yeah yeah definitely
even even if how are they different even
if even if the real videos
i even i would even say the real videos
are even fear mongering as well
because if you look at the statistics i
would say kids are susceptible to get
abduction you can probably go up to any
kid right now and probably
you can snap them easily but it doesn't
happen because it doesn't happen it
doesn't happen yeah i love hearing you
say that
it happens but not as much like the
statues
wanted to adopt a kid you could go and
get it
the fact is it doesn't happen and you
portray a world where it's just that
easy
right so i don't see the difference on
that one i don't see the difference
you're fear-mongering and they're
teaching it in class
yeah i don't know they're idiots for
teaching it
i didn't tell them to teach it in class
they took it upon them i do agree with
you
i'm not like sending it to the school
saying you should teach this in the
sociology class i think there were
probably kids in the class that probably
raised their hand saying hey that's joey
salads some of his videos
i would have said that if i was watching
it some of his videos have been declared
as fake and totally exposed and he even
admitted that
so we should watch this with a grain of
salt
yeah dramatization you could even watch
it is that dramatization
yeah i mean that's that is a [ __ ]
true point anyone who shows that in the
classroom should be
what thing is i've seen it in so many
classrooms because people send us their
screenshots
or i mean they send us pictures and so
many like
all the kobe person yeah that's the one
i see a lot of colby person
no i guess colby person like have my
videos he took the ideas
do you think colby stole from you there
are people that work
i think there's someone that writes
kobe's videos i love that he can't even
write his own
it's like pranks.com what is that [ __ ]
i don't even know i haven't even heard i
haven't seen anything say pranksters.com
in like
two years i mean they used to put in the
beginning of all their videos
yeah i don't see it anymore well i don't
even watch the videos anymore so
somebody out there is writing colby's
pranks
yeah he's like one of the videos was
even
almost word for word it was uh
one of the gold digger ones it was a
private jet gold digger video and i
synced it up like word-for-word it was
like the same exact dialogue
really who released it first i did
sounds like rounds for a lawsuit dude oh
yeah
i love that
um do you hold a grudge for that how do
you feel about that i don't
get more views i mean mine definitely
got more on facebook
i think on youtube he's got more
facebook for sure
dude he ain't touching me on facebook i
can't compete on facebook
um you can't get paid i said i can't
compete i don't really
buy proxy you can't get paid yeah the
thing is your your content
is probably not that good for facebook
it's long form yeah yeah
it's not it's perfect for youtube how
their algorithm
should be yeah favoring view time
were you saying you um people are saying
we promise to get into the ghost stories
okay we should have anything else
welcome to dude welcome to the spooks
and goof
segment of the podcast which
unintentionally became the only part
people care about so here's the premise
i don't believe in ghosts at all i'm a
very skeptical person
i don't believe in ufos i don't believe
any of that [ __ ] wow but i'm
i'm open right because every guest we've
had so far had really
interesting ghost slash ufo stories vac
me and eel have a new ghost story to
share yeah
you have ghost stories and yet you don't
believe in ghosts yeah it just happened
everyone loves this segment but like i
it's a good balance because
a lot of our guests are really into it
and we kind of like okay well maybe
you know it's kind of interesting but
i'm open right so joey salads
let me ask you do you like salad
i actually hate salads do you hate
salads
i hate the sound the smell of it i hate
the crunching sound
there's so many levels to style yeah i
didn't know you could hate
salad on that just meat and a slight bit
of lettuce on top
i'll eat it do you eat vegetables
yeah broccoli carrots that was my two
faves broccoli and carrots
you're sweet you're a sweet kid yeah
that's nice
um wow well i'm kind of disappointed
finding you don't like salads but
regardless on to the second
question do you have any ghost stories i
don't have any ghost stories all right
get out
do you have a ufo story you have a ufo
theory i have old theories on ghosts and
ufos yeah tell me
do you believe in it what goes to your
do you believe in ghosts or ufos
um is it really i believe this and how
does it really affect them
i could make it relate back if you
believe it
don't don't i'm not i'm not a facebook
watcher
give me the [ __ ] give me the real truth
well my theory on ghosts is
i don't really even know if they're
really not it does seem plausible
i feel like there's so much to the
universe and this sounds like stoner
talk but i don't even smoke let's go
but there's so much to the universe that
we can't even comprehend or understand
like there's got to be some other
dimension or parallel reality to this
one
yeah and like the energy and like souls
and when you think about that it's like
religion gives these answers but are
they even real they're like oh you die
about you go to heaven your soul goes to
heaven it's like how do you know that
like for a fact nobody's ever crossed
over no one yeah
you no one's came over and came back
wasn't he taking up body oh you want it
didn't he come back
anyway let's not get into that yeah yeah
jesus he's he's a one-of-a-kind guy yeah
he pulled it off nobody else has so far
um
so yeah basically there's so much that
we don't know like when you die
what what what we are our ability to
think and talk and move and like
self-consciousness like where does that
consciousness go does it just
end when your brain dies when or are you
stuck in like an internal loop
in your brain that feels like an
eternity and that's pretty much what
heaven is
in your brain or it is yours you have a
soul that comes out
and gets goes to another dimension or
heaven or hell or wherever
and if that is true that soul and that
energy of your body
it's possible could be lingering around
and
doing things that you've done a lot
spooking people how do you feel about
your reincarnation anything's possible
we don't know
like how the hell are we supposed to
know but like the
theory like the thought that like
grandma died in this house
and now and then stuff happens that when
you think about it it's like
say that that was plausible to me it's
like if you think like
say that's my grandma's favorite chair
and every other day or
every other week it just reclines
randomly and it's like the grandma
always used to recline the chair every
day probably
i feel like that motion and that thing
of doing something every day and you die
maybe it leaves like some kind of energy
aura that just
continues to do it you know like it's
like mysteries so you just never know
and it's yeah i agree
i agree i i do agree that there's pretty
much
like we don't understand a lot of [ __ ]
just the very
the very idea of existence itself
is like such a weird paradox that it's
yeah and when people say they don't they
don't believe in god because it sounds
like
like a crazy talk to think that's crazy
you believe in it
and a guy in the sky that created
everything it's like is that
any less crazy than us talking to each
other right now and being in existence
what makes it god any less crazy you
know no i agree
although my my idea of god isn't like
well this is
this is spooks and gifts on a different
level but
my idea of god is not someone who like
watches you masturbate or whatever but
like probably
whatever whatever higher power is just
kind of sparked
the beginning right it's like aliens
god is an alien obviously
think about like this if a plane if
we're living three four thousand years
ago
and a plane flows over the sky people
can start worship in that plane
and declare a religion based off what it
looks like and draw pictures of it and
worship it and come up with stories
about it
what makes you example uh when i think
was when moses
uh like escaped with all the slaves
there was a light in the sky that he
followed
and it brought him to safety doesn't
that sound like a ufo he followed
possibly
was it polaris yeah no he said there was
a there was a
i remember like seeing pictures of it in
my in my
own religion class in my book and i'm
like that looks like a ufo like it was
like a light in the sky
that he followed and it guided him and
then when he went up on the mountain and
he got the ten commandments or whatever
right there
in the burning bush and it's like god is
an alien
doesn't it sound like it could have
possibly have been an alien
amount i mean yeah sure
yeah it's fine but if you believe the
story to begin with
yeah exactly um how about this one mary
all right that gave birth to jesus mary
was visited
yes where did the muslims come in and
blow everyone up
back there in the middle of the night
mary was visited by an angel and was
granted a gift of having like she was
just getting
a [ __ ] dick on the side either that
and then she gave more plausible
explanation
she was visited by alien didn't have sex
was just pregnant gave birth to
a human with mystical powers that
everybody started to worship
that mystical person died came back to
life
died again and wasn't he taken up into
heaven body and soul
lifted by the light up into the sky same
thing with mary when mary died lifted
into the light
well does that sound like she was
visited by an alien artificially
inseminated
gave birth to jesus who had enhanced
psychic
capabilities because that's just the
events alien race
and then was taken back up yes jesus was
an x-men
x-men's origins x-men origins it goes
back to jesus
um sean have you ever been spooked oh
i've been spooked plenty of times
are you serious yeah are you not
necessarily ghosts but
okay i didn't expect you to to be a
ghost guy but i'd love for it to be
tell me what you got the most prominent
one i guess i could think of
would be uh i used to go to san
francisco a lot
because we lived like 45 minutes south
of there when we were in university
right and i had a buddy who was painting
the william westerfeld house in alamo
square which is like an old gothic talk
about andrew
victorian yeah so we go party
in the city and i go spend the night in
this spooky ass house
and one night uh i was in just
really plain wood red velvet room just a
bed a rug
an old phonograph uh and like a bureau
so i'm laying in bed pretty pretty
straight like not
you know exaggerated position or
anything and i'm i'm
looking up through my eyelids but i can
see everything that's happening in the
room like
understandably talking to people after
this and reading up about it already
sleep paralysis you could see through
your eyelids yeah exactly
so i know my eyes are closed but i can
see everything that's happening in the
room
and then suddenly there's a man a
red-headed short-haired man standing
next to the bed
he doesn't say anything he he smiles
without showing his teeth i don't know
if i can do it
it looks goofy but it was innocent and
i'm telling myself in my head to wake up
wake up open your eyes
i can feel my body but nothing can move
um and so he actually steps into the bed
so he's like perpendicular with me it's
like a ghost [ __ ] and he turns to face
me
as he's like halfway in my body right
and then i wake up yeah was it was it
like a frightening
presence it was frightening in the sense
that i couldn't control anything but you
didn't feel but i was there
presence of mind and everything no he
was very innocent huh
now when you go to sleep can you control
your dreams like lucid dreaming
no see when i when i go if
a while ago i used to practice how to
lucid dream and you just go in there and
you control everything like you're the
[ __ ] like
you're you're a freaking x-men and i
used to when i used to try to do that
that would happen to me the sleep
paralysis okay
and because i i don't know why because i
go to sleep just thinking of doing it
and then like sometimes when i'm falling
asleep i feel it coming yeah
and then yeah you know it's gonna happen
when you go to sleep like because you
have like
a clock you have to wake up like yeah
immediately or you'll be just trapped
yeah yeah so then it happens and it's
like i know i'm in it
and it's like you don't even know what
it is it's like you're like awake but
like half sleeping or
are you just like totally asleep or
what's spooky weird happening than any
ghost story ever
because it's [ __ ] wrong i actually
have a good story when you're done i
just thought of one
so i actually have always had chronic
sleep paralysis
usually i've read that it's like a
symptom of people with
epilepsy with a seizure disorder often
have chronic sleep paralysis
i have a i think it has something to do
with my tourette's
or something like that but i have it
sometimes the worst is when you get it
when you're falling asleep because
it's like how the [ __ ] like that happens
briefly and it stopped thank god it
always happens when i wake up
and it's always the same i must have had
this dream hundreds of times in my life
where i just wake up and i'm in an
infinite white void
and i'm laying down and like um
i'm just completely paralyzed in an
infinite white void and i'm like super
anxious
and like because i have tourette's i
always have the need to like fidget and
move my fingers and [ __ ] and like flex
my muscles is like part of my tics my
ocd
but i can't do it because i'm paralyzed
so like i get like super anxious because
i really want to like fidget
yeah and i'm stuck there in this
infinite white void just like trying
crazy
always trying to sit up and um
just sounds terrible and i'm fully
conscious i'm fully conscious
and like sometimes this [ __ ] happens
where you can hear stuff around you and
you feel
like you can understand things are
happening around you but after
encountering it
like hundreds of times i think i
realized that it's all part of the dream
like it's super convincing like i hear
my mom cooking breakfast or some [ __ ] or
i have the television on the living room
and i'm
sure that that's actually happening
but i i think i've come to realize that
it's all part of the dream okay
yeah it makes sense your brain's
controlling everything if something's
going on in there it's kind of like
people totally hallucinate and they
believe that they're seeing spiders
running on the table and it's not there
but sometimes it goes on for like 30
seconds
and sometimes it will go on for like i
swear like maybe a half an hour
damn and that is still happening to you
it comes in waves
like sometimes i'll get it a lot it it
happened the most when i was like
a teenager young teenager so i get it
sometimes now
but like when it goes on and on dude
i'll wake up and i'll be like i'm never
i'm never going to sleep again and the
worst part is that when i experience it
i wake up
super tired so like my body
wants just to fall asleep like more than
anything like
my heart was probably racist my heart's
racing i'm super anxious and in my dream
i'm like i'm never [ __ ] sleeping
again but when i wake up
i'm like so overcome by tiredness
that it's kind of horrifying too because
i know i'm about to fall asleep again
and i really don't want to
and i'll fall asleep and i'll slip right
back into the paralysis
so it's like your brain is still firing
off chemicals are still going
yes and you're never getting the chance
to actually rest
well you i think what happens is i wake
up my body never gives me like the wake
up chemical
so when i wake up i'm still like deep
sleep because what i read is it happens
when your body doesn't give you that
kick
have people have the same exact dream as
you i've never heard of someone who had
the same exact paralysis try looking up
like forms maybe
maybe like people with like because
sometimes like this website so you talk
about like tourette's or like sleep
paralysis
and people share their stories you might
see something similar
could have answers my theory is that it
like it has a lot to do with like the
helplessness
that i experience by having tourette's
because i'm so like
subconsciously i just can't control it
like i can't control it really
yeah the ticking it's out of our hands i
feel like you have a fidget spinner
i [ __ ] hate i play with the fidget
spinner the first time i hate it
it drives me it makes me anxious it
drives me crazy because i came like
super obsessed oh yeah i can't put it
down i'm like [ __ ] this thing's driving
crazy it's just
adding it's just feet in the face yeah i
hate it you know
you don't know what fidget spinner is no
damn dog
[ __ ] i'm guessing it's something you
hold in here it's like it's everywhere
it's this uh it's on like a
swim yeah a bearing and it's got three
sides and you just spin it and you hold
it
right that's that's it and it's super
popular the kids
[ __ ] love it i used it once and i got
addicted
and i put it down i didn't like it
whenever i see it i pick them up
but that's the thing i always pick it up
yeah just this thing
oh it looks like uh that guy from
futurama
right clamps what i don't remember that
okay clamps
but anyway that was that's how did you
make that comparison
that's what it looks like it does there
was one time when i was having sleep
paralysis it was only happened once at
the hundreds of times
it was it was probably the most
terrified i've ever been in my life i
was like okay
here i am because when it happens i'm
like okay just be calm
just wait be patient right that's what
i'm telling myself and out of the
infinite white void came like a [ __ ]
demon
face and it like flew up in my face and
was like growling
and i was and it never happened before
it never happened since but i was
[ __ ]
my heart was pounding dude and i was so
scared
i was [ __ ] that was horrifying i know
it's hard to translate that into
a shareable experience but yeah yeah
it's awful
um what's your ghost story it's not even
meister it's my dad's story
okay this is good this is good yeah so i
always got something to share yeah let's
go
i don't know i see when i ever think of
ghost stories i'm like there's got to be
some kind of logical scientific
explanation to it
and i'll tell you what my scientific
explanation what i think could have been
it but it doesn't seem to hold much
weight because it sounds kind of stupid
but also it's my daddy he could be
[ __ ]
um he told me this story like a bunch of
times and
the picture in the store he actually
showed me like
a few years ago and it's a scary [ __ ]
picture anyways
my grandma when my dad was younger
probably like in his teenagers
or pre-teens whatever age he was um my
grandma got a brand new
photo of a saint i forgot what saint it
was but it was like the patron saint of
children
looking photo from like the six this is
the patron saint of children yeah
there's like some course
of sports saved children probably [ __ ]
kids like yeah for sure
so my grandma put it on her wall
and like it's like say this is a wall
this is my dad's bed
and that's like my was my grandparent's
bed so it's on the wall
and my dad had was left alone the entire
day into the next day because
grandparents went away and he was left
to the house for over over a whole day
what was his age at the time he had to
be in his teens or pre-teens
okay it was young he was young it not
like too young
but he was like old enough to be old
enough to yeah
experience something like that yeah so
what happened was he woke up in the
middle of the night
oh they didn't wake up the middle night
before he went to bed he cooked
something
and he went back to sleep and
as he's going to sleep well i think he
said he fell asleep
and then he woke up to like
on the wall behind him and he goes in
to my his parents room i'm staying in
bed
at that point and he sees that the pitch
has moved
so he readjusts the picture fixes it it
stops
rattling he goes back to bed falls
asleep here's it again
are you making this [ __ ] up
grab your leg for the table he goes he
fixes it again
and he's like now that i'm up let me
just go into the kitchen
whatever he was making something to eat
or we want to get his little snack
he went up he was totally fine he wasn't
like spooked straight
i don't i don't know i would have
shouldn't be back then man yeah because
he's like oh the ghost is
back you know what it is i mean you wake
up twice to rearrange a picture to start
right
ghost sounds and then he goes to the
kitchen
finds out he left the the gas on
on the stove so he fixes it whenever
he's like oh [ __ ] he fixes it
goes back to bed and it stopped patron
saint of the children
so like that could have saved his life
like the house could have blown up one
little spark and just blew up the whole
house
jimmy seville the savior and then he
[ __ ] him always went to bed afterwards
yeah
then he had a wet dream then
like special yeah i'll take it
you want to tell them about our what
happened to us this week
um this week you had a ghost encounter
so and since we've been having the
spooks
and goof segment i've been like kind of
heightened awareness on this [ __ ]
so we watch so he has the picture we
took a pic so i'm lying in bed
it's probably about 12 o'clock and i'm
like
elo why is our wall bleeding like i say
it jokingly
and then so ela's like yeah i just
noticed it today as well
and we're like wait that clearly wasn't
there because it's next to our
alarm and i'm there every night to set
it it clearly wasn't there
it's like in the background is there
anything no we don't
we don't eat there we don't do anything
there it's the wall next to the tv like
there's no way
indoor in our bedroom in a corner that
we don't frequent i only go there to set
the alarm and i leave
why the [ __ ] we've never noticed it
before whether it be a
run a red drip like a good hefty drip
a red run huh
you should have scraped it off and
tasted it i smelled it
and then so i said don't even touch it i
touched it and it was like don't do it i
was like
what am i getting ghost aids sorry you
get aids
that's how you get aids anyway and then
i took my dick out i rubbed it on it
a little closer so like what the hell
i was i was genuinely spooked probably
it's darker and
like the picture it looks lighter but it
was darker and really good
it looked like dried blood yeah and like
i think for the first time my life i was
like this
is [ __ ] creepy i would move out right
away so then i'm on account of that
so we me and eli sat together and we're
like okay we don't believe in ghosts
there has to be
a [ __ ] explanation for this but we
were actually like scared
yeah there was 10 minutes and i was like
i can't handle this [ __ ]
so we're thinking about it we're sitting
there
and then i i look closely at a little
closer at this blood state and i'm like
well
it's kind of more brown than red
yeah like i feel like if it was dried
blood it would be more
a kind of darker rustier color right
yeah so it kind of looks like too brown
to be blood
it's poop yeah and then i realized oh
this is where it is and then i realized
there was a giant moth like a really
really big moth
that was stuck in our bedroom like a
couple nights
the night before like one of the biggest
moms i've ever seen and it was on that
wall that side of the bedroom so it's
moth poop i think that what it is
that's actually just a giant
[ __ ] but if he just exploded
no he was there we spotted him
afterwards not at the same moment
it was the day yeah i think it's just a
giant moth poop
immortalized forever on the internet
that's something
that's kind of interesting i mean i i'm
that makes sense yeah it makes sense
the fact that it's weight carried it
down that far but like that was like a
hefty drop
and you touched it by the way i touched
it yeah well i was like
trying to see what what the consistency
was because
i was spooked man i wanted to get to the
bottom of this [ __ ] so it was just a
giant moment
logic and reason prevailed yeah and you
discovered this
we figured it out we did but that was
the longest i've gone like
like 10 minutes of like what the [ __ ]
seriously
oh man that was that was straight up
spook spooksville
um what else what else that's it
that's it so we're done no i mean that's
it with the stories
joey are you still running for mirror i
was gonna but then i faked
an experiment got exposed wait what were
you planning to do
i was planning on doing either web
series or or we were pitching it for a
tv show
and then when all that [ __ ] went down i
was like forget it i was like what the
fake
prank [ __ ] yeah so i was like you know
what forget it too much [ __ ] going on
i go i'll hold it off until whenever
until all this dies down until it all
dies
i mean in four years it's no one's
probably gonna talk about it anymore
what the the mayor thing four years
since what
all the although all my meme controversy
of last year
everything that i did you said four
years
oh yeah that's when the next election
would be okay because this is
this election so like in four years if i
try to do it then i'm gonna vote i'll
cut i'm one joey cell to be married
maybe yeah right you're gonna like round
up all the members of what city yeah
so he's gonna like start a straight up
concentration camp he's like yep i'll do
that
[Laughter]
i am curious though because that fake
trump car in the black neighborhood
experiment was kind of one of the
biggest like
exposes in history i think so what sucks
is yeah i'm sorry
i was going to say i was just going to
ask you generally what has the fallout
been from that
it was bad at first massive amount of
hate
um from left and right side of course
but the left side because the right
people ate it up they
were [ __ ] super hooked in from that
they must have felt really betrayed yeah
but i've actually gained back a lot of
trust
from people on the right since then uh
by just doing the videos for real do you
think that it's right of them that
they're
do you think they should trust you no
they should they shouldn't trust me i've
said it
on uh tim poole's uh pot
it was in pal case it's like an
interview because he's like a journalist
reporter and sometimes we do stuff
on similar stuff i even said it to him
i'm like no people shouldn't trust me
but at the same time they shouldn't
trust anybody or anything or take
anything at face value to
just always question everything and all
the time like whenever they're presented
with stuff like that
um but i mean like i made like an oath
to myself and to my now
political viewers you know moving
forward anything political is going to
be 100 real
is that your focus now is politically
charged content no
it was at once mostly abductions
whatever i feel
would go viral at the time i'll do um
but it was like when the election was
hot that's when it was mostly political
stuff well that video you made was
[ __ ] huge with all the black
the black boys beating up that trumpy
car
yeah that was you have a new thing going
on right the joey and tanisha
yeah so i'm also trying to there's less
controversy in just doing dumb pranks
and also we
fake of course the viewers could easily
decide that
and like another one where you destroyed
your makeup and i was like come on
yeah i mean i watch facebook videos
especially facebook pranks especially
relationship pranks i'm like
this shit's funny i could do better yeah
i could do it better it's awesome yeah
is that your real girlfriend yeah why
would i fake a girlfriend i was well
josh
what are you asking i thought it's
probably fake the relationship yeah
they're relationships really yeah
wow that's messed up
we found the line we actually just
uploaded a skit today
we're going to move towards guests and
it's actually doing pretty well
um so yeah we're gonna try to move to do
like more skits there's less conscious
very seeing that because the worst you
get is a stupid and fake
like if i do a political thing that's
stupid and fake it's
and then a lot more brutal well yeah and
it is
yeah if you fake a political thing yeah
it's
manipulated yeah but the problem is
my page for like those couple of days
got massive amount of hate lost massive
amount of subscribers
lost support on both sides but then
adam saleh i hate the point the finger
and fouseytube
they've done stuff that you can even
consider as equally as bad
but because they're not white here we go
they get kind of a pass is that like
bringing it back
bigotry of low expectations it's like
they don't get it passed okay
i don't even think they get that but
their fans gave them hold on hold on
hold on hold on
let's back it up everybody hates those
guys everybody does but their fans love
them
that's because you need to run a cult
that's true you don't you don't
call on islamism
no you don't have fans like you're not
you don't have a cult of personality
like fouseytube
is this all this whole smile more what
up
you know like they have they have this
this cult of personality that you don't
have
i have people hate those guys don't
think that there's a double standard
yeah
but also at the same time i don't even
think they got i wouldn't
let's look at this um adam saleh two
examples real quick
he faked the [ __ ] he faked well yeah
that the airplane was the most recent
one but he faked um
him getting arrested by white cops
because he was muslim
that is pretty bad yeah no i agree
that's really bad really bad like
and then he he faked that whole delta
airlines stuff which was just total
[ __ ]
that was worse than the first one and
that got a
crazy amount of publicity and press but
annie got [ __ ]
did we make a video about that being
fake i think everyone did so whenever
everyone yeah everyone was talking about
it so we just but maybe because it
the hate that happened to me it seemed a
little bit worse but i feel like
i even got it probably worse than he did
because his stuff was still being
defended
like the ideology and the point that he
was the same thing to the trump car
yeah but you're like well that would
happen yeah but i didn't have one person
that's
that still supported you didn't do that
there were there were people there's
probably very few minority
but i don't think i think it's a false
equivalent to be like well they're
i'm white so i got it like no one even
talks about his instance anymore but
nobody cares about them anyway
that guy is nobody nobody cares you
don't know how much [ __ ] foods youtube
yeah fouseytube yeah dude but his like
ratio is
still well actually his like ratio went
down i'm actually surprised by his like
ratio
i'll be honest with you but he has that
quality personality but everybody like
everyone on youtube does not like food
too yeah i don't think but what has he
done
on par with i believe they take
advantage of their muslim audience
i don't know if they take advantage of
it but they have a lot of they have i
think they take advantage of them
because i know they're they like to
preach this whole
i'm a super islam whatever and they uh
you know
fouseytube removed his tattoos once
because he's like this is when i was in
a bad state of mind and you know
i went against you know my my my
religion so i'm getting removed to show
good
now he's got like a half a sleeve i
think or also leave he just went again
same thing with like adam saleh he
preaches no drinking none of this none
of that
living a good healthy muslim life but
then pictures come out that show
otherwise of him
i think that's just their shitty
character yeah i don't think it's the
fact that
i mean the fact that they're muslim
maybe they're using it but they're also
they'll use anything yeah
they're that's just what's available
they're pretending to be inspirational
and they use that yeah oh that's so true
yeah they're using that to pull in
those following and it's just not
genuine it's just all lies like i come
on here i tell you guys this is fake
that's fake
i'm fear-mongering like what is
fouseytube done that's as bad as faking
a trump street fighter bonus level i
remember keemstar did a video on him
i forgot what he was talking about but i
remember at the time i was like
this is pretty bad probably not as bad i
was like this is pretty bad
i forgot i forgot what it was to be
honest with you
yeah i don't know i remember he did some
bad stuff but
he didn't really he like exposed himself
like
a year after the videos came out and
that was like before the exposing stuff
was hardcore
now it's like you expose a prank and
it's like because of [ __ ] yeah nobody
cares
we are we know already well the prank
that how how's the youtube
adpocalypse you the prank the whole
prank genre is kind of dead like
people think that we stopped doing
reactions because we're being sued but
it's actually just because there's like
not there's not a lot of good content
out there all this like really
cancerous shitty horrible content is not
making money on youtube
anymore so people aren't making it
mm-hmm like look at the
bradbury boys now they're doing sunset
park for christmas yeah
prank stuff is like on the low scale of
monetization as well
i'm sure it's it's
low length yeah and usually really bad
just
gives it worse cpm yeah generally it's
usually like
i said i get to yeah yeah
what are you gonna do i gotta get
facebook monetization
i gotta start doing live yeah hopefully
it comes in full strength soon
me and eli we should start doing couples
pranks you should
no i'm gonna practice a parody of it i'm
gonna break all your makeup in the sink
ela
yeah i'm gonna punch you in the stomach
when you're pregnant i'm good
break your nintendo switch yeah so i'm
gonna say she's gonna
hit you with the uh positive pregnancy
test oh
classic i'd be happy that would be like
a twist that'd be really sad
because i'd be happy and then she'd be
like psych yeah
and then i'd be like damn that's
horrible i was gonna prank my grandma
with that
and tell her because she's a hardcore uh
christian
so we were gonna tell her that uh we
were gonna get an abortion
and she probably would have started
crying but
i was gonna give her a photo of uh
because of the ultrasound
no no no a different prank i was gonna
give her a photo of you know obi-wan
kenobi
from the first three star wars movies
yeah i was going to give her a photo of
him and say here's a picture of jesus i
got you
because if you look up a photo just
because you're like this is how
not into christianity i am well no like
as in like
how clueless she is wouldn't movies with
the
young generation and like oh she'd
actually think that it was jesus yeah
she would think it's jesus yeah did you
try it
i didn't try it i had the photo printed
out and i'm like you couldn't force
yourself
i couldn't do it actually i wanted to do
it well let's find out
no don't don't post it let's just do a
social experiment maybe you can come on
again and report
yeah on your finding yeah she'll yeah
she'll know she'll think it's jesus
like viewers right now look up photos of
obi-wan kenobi and then jesus next to it
i mean you'll see like side-by-side
comparisons did jesus walk around in a
like a brown robe
i don't know but you can ask moses jesus
was obviously a very beautiful
guy you're a white european that's how
he's represented yeah see
this meme right here jesus was like a
black guy
well if he was born in that part of the
world more than exactly
it's like a [ __ ] but in any culture
where christianity is prevalent he takes
on
features and characteristics of the
population oh
i thought you were talking about the
original one yeah that looks like jesus
yeah
that definitely looks like jesus oh well
that's not even like
that's not even surprising yeah just
like it looks like a jesus shot
yeah like and type wait go back what was
that dumb ass meme
like and type amen if you love jesus and
lightsaber battles
oh god it's so stupid
what is this one with all the writing
mom that's not a picture of jesus one
man died for all
who is this man you mcgregor as obi-wan
how does his death help us becomes a
voice in your head
reminding you to use the force why is it
important that we remember him
death stars ain't going to blow
themselves up that really does look like
obi-wan god damn
that's wonderful yeah all right
how we doing listen let's wrap it up i
think it's been about two hours
cool all right anything else you guys
want to talk about um
you want anything um
what do you got i guess i got one thing
but i don't know if it's
could it probably be a short one let's
go whatever you got wait on us
i don't know it's not i don't know if
it's that interesting but it's it's
referring to
money and getting around youtube and
stuff like that so i hit you up and i
think did you ever come out with a game
phone game it's something that's being
developed
we're like thinking about it yeah
there's some people there's there's
a company that we really like that we're
talking with
you they're not developing anything yet
didn't start anything yet we're planning
it oh nice nice
so yes um today the company that
i pretty much co-founded we just came
out with a new game today
and to get around basically because i i
don't trust
youtube and facebook and any any social
media ad revenues or anything like that
i don't trust it they can come crashing
down like
twitter screwed me over at one point but
i was and new people
was able to get it undone like they
weren't going to pay me at one point
facebook can go down and you imagine
mike from twitter yeah it's pretty good
there's cpm some months will be like 10.
because we got twitter monetization and
we tried it on a couple of videos it was
like
[ __ ] nothing some months are like
actually nothing
and others could be like 10 20 bucks
like i
had like december was like almost 20
bucks like 18 bucks some days
what the [ __ ] yeah i was like what this
is insane oh my god
so that's it none of it's reliable yeah
like you can't trust anything
like you see what happened with youtube
like you probably knew that was gonna
happen i knew something like that
honestly it was even beyond what i
thought was possible
i thought i actually predicted it i did
a podcast
way long ago and i predicted i'm like if
trump wins
i feel like people on the left that just
run everything
are going to have like an all-right
attack on like advertiser spending
that's not what happened that may not be
what happened i believe that
that is partially what happened due to
the controversy i've seen
there's like this huge controversy among
like right-wing newscasters on youtube
they act like they're the only ones hit
right it's not the [ __ ] case
this guy uh what's the name of that
left-wing news show
that guy was making zero he was making
nothing and he was super
pac-man show he does like left-wing news
he made zero it's not
uh yeah no i think it definitely
affected people on both sides
equally i think it disproportionately
affected people on the right
the young i think we're i think what
you're having uh the young turks are
having a fallacy exactly the young turks
is the exception because
they're friends with people from youtube
but also look at not because of their
political look at
buzzfeed attn all the
it's because they have connections to
youtube yeah that is
mainly but can you picture a right-wing
company
of that scale on youtube that has
monetization like that what about
the closest information they've lost
monetization probably on
most i know they talk about although to
be honest infowars also talks about
[ __ ] you know their conspiracies to
make frogs gay
yeah they
yeah i wouldn't even consider them a
right-wing source just like
conspiracy [ __ ] posts crazy stuff yeah
like pretty much you always see the alex
yeah you see alex jones on joe rogan oh
man i saw clifford
best podcast i ever watched like three
and a half he got it the whole thing
you know he got weird like
when he started talking about
dimensional [ __ ] seems like a great
podcast guest you should get them on
get him on i would tell him hit him up
tell him be like hey i have a young
audience they're very impressionable
their minds are like sponges he'll come
in and he'll just lay some likes
i'd love you just don't even have to
talk you just be like go yeah just
alex jones would be amazing if anyone
knows alex jones get him on this show
yeah start tweeting at alex jones i'd
love to have him
yeah there you go i'm not sure i don't
even know how to confront something
right
you gotta let me know if he comes i'm
coming through all right i gotta come
through it's gonna be a whole
yeah you'll have an audience it's gonna
be the one anyway what was the point of
your
where were you getting um are you making
a game is that what it was oh yeah it
came out it's called dashy box everyone
go download it day she box
dashie dashy box dashy like dashing
around got it
yeah but yeah if you don't want me to
make videos anymore
they're too cringy for you if this app
does well i won't need to make videos so
there you go
i gotta support
you got this entrepreneurial spirit all
you pranksters are out like
not all of them but you and like their
bradberrys and colby person
you guys all have this like entrepreneur
spirit you're all like out there
hustling finding ways to make money that
i never even thought of
because i mean if you if you think about
it stemmed from majority being
fake that's that that's how it started
you guys were
opportunists yeah it's like we don't
really like i have
blast doing the ones that are real i
have a lot of fun doing those but at the
same time we're like we see something
where we can make money
you know how we could finagle some stuff
you see it as a business first yes
it's like for us it's like make an
interesting video first you know i mean
it's it's just it's a different approach
but i see what you mean you guys are
like hustlers
yeah we come out with the video game as
hustlers yeah i mean but i have always
made videos since
since the dawn of youtube but i made
skits right
skits aren't doing [ __ ] in those kids so
then i'm like i discovered
more pranking stuff and i'm like this
stuff just killing it i think that's
generally
i'm not i'm not talking about you but
generally i think that pranksters are
low character
i can see that okay well i mean you've
done some little character things just
be honest
i'm not gonna give you a full write-off
well like unscrupulous
right because it's like very
opportunistic
very like you don't do this thing and
this is what i i
do find endearing about you like the
fouseytube the roman atwood thing where
they're like
smile more guys be happy i'm here
i'm here because we're all [ __ ] love
life and i just think that we're all
just the best
like this whole fake ass like turn off
the camera and shout
your girlfriend yeah right like ah
it's so fake dude so you definitely
didn't take it as far as some of those
guys and i don't believe for a second
that any of that [ __ ] is genuine
no i don't i don't believe it either
it's all [ __ ] um before we end it i
think
people really want you to talk about the
pain the mouth
incident the early days yeah they
weren't talking about the peeing in the
mountains in it yeah they really don't
know the full story of the incident yeah
i thought everyone knew it but i guess
maybe not because
people still post it on my facebook page
they'll post it in the comments
like your grandma's seen that one i hope
not
well that's [ __ ] awesome because
you're you're pushing this content with
120
million views and the top comment every
time it's got to be you pissing in your
mouth not every time but like sometimes
i'll scroll through and i'll see it
would it be like
[ __ ] great do you delete it you blog
my banned list on facebook is incredible
i'm sure um
i'm like i'm not bringing this hate here
i'm keeping i'm keeping it out oh yeah
yeah so for those who are not initiated
joey famously
there was a clip that surfaced of joey
pissing in his mouth and then a bunch of
his friends like
they were all having a giggle having a
laugh when it first came out
the story was so misconstrued keemstar
[ __ ] up every single news story
i think it was him at first saying he
was saying like a cell phone footage
emerged of me
pissing in my mouth no context added no
reasoning why
took it at face value but after you look
into the story
we were filming a really shitty low
budget jackass movie
that we thought was going to do good
well tv thought was in do good
starts no no nfg i remember there was
some really fun good stuff in there that
i enjoyed doing
i had a blast doing it but it was end of
the day it wasn't that good
um i peed in my mouth and i didn't
swallow it i spit it out you gargled i
remember gargled it yeah
it's been on my friend it seemed like
you're having a lot of fun doing it it
was fun
it was nice how was the experience it
was extremely salty yeah
it was it was were you well hiding there
was more water yeah a room of my friends
old dudes just watching me pee in my
mouth it seemed like a good time
everyone was laughing having a good time
yeah
did you who cleaned up the urine on the
floor you left it
where were you uh it was in our
apartment complex in the
office room it was inside you peed on
the floor
yeah and you left it on a rug so it
soaked in nice people
were you the only one to pee in their
mouth ladies and gentlemen but a lot of
people are like
you're crazy you're stupid like this is
disgusting it's like word in the context
of us making a dumb jackass parody
[ __ ] stevo drank drank horse semen
like
what's worse stringing your own piss and
spitting it out or drinking horse semen
so what about i think the context
matters
it's in the context of a shitty well
ours were shitty there's a wannabe
jackass movie
and it's like they do disgusting bear
grylls drinks his own urine now
like where all the other videos part of
the same thing there were like videos of
you
the dick in the bun no that that's a
whole nother story oh yeah
okay like okay and then let's get in we
should have gotten this stuff earlier
and then around that same time joey
there was picture servicing of joey
having a great time having a laugh lots
of smiles putting his
dick semi-erect dick into a hot dog bun
and apparently that was a really
starting it up yeah putting mustard on
it
tell me about that so that was around
probably like the same week at the same
time
yeah we were just [ __ ] around
literally
on snapchat we were gaining all these
followers and then this is
people think that i made a tumblr page
of just naked pictures of me and naked
pictures of other guys and it was
my dick on the cover with sprinkles on
it
no i we put a couple [ __ ] with
sprinkles no
no sprinkles touched my dick maybe once
in a weird
sexual encounter that's just
inappropriate but no
it goes it looks like an ice cream it's
weird so
a lot of people thought a lot of stuff
were my weird stuff
that weren't my weird stuff just because
it was mixed in with my actual weird
stuff
right right right right but you had
actual words i had actual weird stuff
that
rivaled that other weird stuff but not
all the weird stuff was my weird stuff
yeah so what happened why were you
putting your dick in the in the bun
i was getting it so many folks also like
you had one friend there who was always
with you and he seemed to be enjoying it
like
more than a straight man there's
anything wrong with that when you're a
bunch of bros living together
you get very comfortable with sexuality
like we all see each other naked like we
all seeing each other like
after one banged a girl we walk out butt
naked you know
you ever see your friends they can be
like nice doug no we never do that
we comment on each other's dick but i
won't be like that's nice dick really
that's scary
that's okay there's nothing wrong with
being gay i have tons of gay followers
but that's good
have you ever commented on your friend's
dick been like dude well like sometimes
like
i'm not going to say which friend but
like he'll have like a rash and he'll be
like yo what do you think about this
and i'm like nice dick it's rash
jerking off too much man wait your
friend got
jerk off burn um what did he have he
should probably see a doctor about it no
like i have one friend that gets
multiple problems with his dick with
like rashes and stuff
and i don't know if i could handle him
like coming up to me and flipping his
dick
what do you think about this i guess
it's that jersey something that evolves
over time
it doesn't just happen you had to be
like
really close but that was like stuff it
wasn't on my snapchat i was on my
friends
so you were sharing these dicks in the
buns on snapchat and you were blowing up
as a result yeah
yep how about that that was about it and
then and then
like why didn't you follow that thread
like what happened with that
i realized this is bad like i shouldn't
be doing this
this could hurt your chances as mayor
yeah this is gonna get brought up in
four years
yeah i'm gonna put it on the thing
behind me and i'll just have to run with
it and be like i'm
pro gay for the course though how many
other politicians are sending pictures
of their genitals
anthony weiner yeah not even just in the
freaking
in the undies man i don't know if he
ever exposes
maybe well anyway it's got to be you
sometimes that means putting your dick
in a bun you gotta be you
but i love that you peed in the office
and kept it there that's a nice detail
do you feel bad about that at all no
it's looking back now
nice how would i have cleaned it and
it'd be weird cleaning up your own urine
yeah fair enough leave it well what are
you doing way more normal for someone
else to clean it
i leave it on the seat you sit down on
it number two
i'll wipe i only wipe the seat if like
i'm in someone else's house that's nice
what about your girlfriend if you pee on
your seat and she goes to use the
restroom you're not going to clean it up
for her
well she's watching now that's the
gentlemanly thing to do she's
seen it text me have you seen my piss on
the seat tanisha
i don't know i think she probably has
it's all gonna break sometimes i miss it
hits the floor
she saw that video and she got pissed oh
yeah the one
the one that the interview yeah you
mentioned that how what was that i met
we were talking and you you were kept
you were asking me to remove that video
right the interview
i don't think i actually remember i
think i asked you to take joey's house
out of the title okay
yeah because your girlfriend had seen it
she was pissed
yeah and i wanted to do a follow-up
video on it talking about it
what part was she pissed off all like
everything in general
just that it happened because she didn't
know about it the the event occurring
because she discovered it through your
video got it cut it so she didn't know
what you were doing um like it's like
you know when you like first meet
somebody like i don't know much
you know she just said sometimes she
finds piss on the seat
um it's it's cool and
it's cool for now once today joey just
watch our videos
just yeah she was like she was like drop
dead like in love with me this is a
perfect guy
so perfect and then she discovered typed
my name in on youtube and it was like
who the [ __ ] am i dating yeah once she
got to know me
she was like she's cool with it now
though she's cool with it now
she's cool i mean things changed in like
the last year
not not doing that you're a new man a
whole new guy people grow
people get older and learn from their
mistakes they move on
do you regret it or do you were like i
was chasing that
that cheddar i mean at the time it
seemed like a good idea but obviously
you look back and you're like i
shouldn't have done that but at the same
time you're like if that didn't happen
i would have just kept doing it so it
probably is better off that it did
happen then
you know it's a good way to look at it
yeah i don't ever look back in life and
say
i should go back and fix that or change
i don't look at life like that i look at
life it's just moving forward right
because one you can't go back and do
anything too i don't ever fully regret
anything i did because i always believe
in everything is like happens for a
reason or eventually
you can turn anything into like a good
outcome so yeah
that's a really inspiring joke yeah you
should start an inspirational channel
you should you should you need to do it
you're going to see me as an ad you see
this right here
dude do you need to mobilize the joey
saladers
salad boys you need to start like a
thing to rival fouseytube
like the salad boys what would you call
joey salads click
what what would you call joey salads
click the saladinos the salad boys
does it have to have salad in the cubs
the cobs cops
caesars man the caesars the little
caesars the little caesars
salad heads classic salad well thanks
for coming
and joining us i genuinely have a
fondness in my heart for you
because you've always been real and
you've and you're always someone who's
been like
i recognize i did this and it's dumb and
it's bad what you've said here today
and like and you're fully justified and
making fun of it
yeah which is so rare amongst pranksters
and i and i appreciate that and like i
don't know
i i appreciate your realness i really do
thank you it's endearing
even though you're a salad head i'm yeah
i'll always be a salad but that's just
things i gotta do
i gotta do something dumb to me myself
out
the thing is you created the meme you
just took something i did and you made
it into a meme
like the boob coming out thing no one
said anything about until you said
something about it like
poop coming out oh man no i'm just
i i think you're i like you doug thanks
dude appreciate you
sean
oh thanks for having me that was fun it
was cool hanging out yeah oh shout out
to my boy gert
real quick maybe you're still watching i
don't know
like yogurt like yogurt dirty boy
boy do you use anything you want to plug
the game um
make a billion dollars where can we find
yours
well if you guys want to watch me play
video games poorly
uh maybe just stop by and chat you can
go to my twitch channel
sean stinks love it yeah if you're into
music you can check out my etsy shop
making some cool instruments too and are
you still doing vlogs on youtube
yeah we do vlogs from time to time but
twitch is the focus for now twitch sean
stinks check it out
yeah sometimes i pop in for a little
damage yeah that's good
heal it she's like i'm just kidding
we got a lot uh anyway guys thanks for
watching
appreciate you so much and um
it's getting real hot in here since we
turned off days did we do that
it was just me really bad
all right so guys we'll see you next
week thanks for watching we appreciate
you we love you
tata well